- And I'll take five suggestions.
I'll divide you up so
everyone gets a fair go.
Let's come to this wedge first.
What would you like to hear a rap about?
World peace?
Do you have any particular
insight as to how
we can achieve world peace?
What do you think is
the path to world peace?
I know this has probably had
think tanks all over it...
Put women in charge, wonderful stuff.
Um, that's uh, I mean, you have
a formidable group of backers over there.
They're like "woo, yeah, women!"
Cool.
Putting women in charge,
women in charge, leading
to world peace.
I like that.
If you are on this side
of the room over here
what would you like a rap about?
Oh, I heard homeschooling.
And what'd you say?
- [Audience Member] Pole vaulting!
- Pole vaulting and homeschooling.
Okay. Home homeschooling
someone in the pole vault.
That sounds good.
So women being leaders
and leading to world peace
homeschool pole vaulting.
Let's come to the very back of the room
If you're in the back, what
do you want a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Black history month!
- I think, I think I
heard black history month.
Is that correct?
Yeah. Yeah.
Represent. That's what we do.
So, world peace as a result
of women being in charge,
homeschool pole vaulting,
black history month.
let's come to the, the middle of the room.
If you are on this section of it,
what do you want a rap about?
Dodgers. I've done,
I've done a recent rap about
the Dodgers, I'm afraid.
Like I said, don't do the same.
The Oscars?
Oh, is there a moment from the Oscars
you want us to focus on?
Parasite, oh parasite
winning the winning the
I mean four, four awards, I think, yeah.
It's a, it's a bomb movie.
It's pretty great.
Don't know if you saw that Trump
spoke about it in his rally today?
Um, yeah, he was not a fan of it.
Um, so let's come to you guys over here.
You guys haven't had a go yet.
What?
- [Audience Member] Harry Potter!
- Okay. You have to be more specific.
Harry Potter gets suggested a lot.
It's very general.
So what, what would you
like us to focus on?
- [Audience Member] On his wand.
- On his wand?
(audience laughter)
You've really tickled some
filthy minded individuals here.
Okay. Those are your suggestions then,
these are what you've come up with.
So on your own heads be
it, the suggestions to
remind you, world peace as a result
of women being in charge.
Black history month, um
pole vaulting homeschooling,
Harry Potter's wand, and
Parasite at the Oscars.
This then, lovely people of
the comedy and magic club.
It's going to be a freestyle rap.
As I said, a rap made up on the spot
based entirely on those suggestions.
It's never been seen before.
It'll never be seen again.
And do not worry,
it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously,
embarrassingly, toe curlingly bad.
As you are expecting a privately
educated middle-class white boy to be.
You seem very convinced.
Let's, let's drop that beat goodsir.
Show them how we do it.
And you can pump it up
a little bit as well.
In my chair on Oscar
night, I was fingers crossed
and hoping that Parasite might win.
I loved that flick so much.
I'm like whoa, Bong Joon
take it off the hook.
I wanna see all of the films
Kind of either,
raking it in, Okja
Snowpiercer, if you haven't
seen his filmatic oeuvre
I should have said cinematic
should have take care
of when I saw him up there
claiming the gong, I was like
I hope they haven't got this wrong.
Like La La Land and Moonlight?
They read the envelope wrong, not right
but now they were correctly
speaking, seeing all this film
it's reaching a whole
new audience out of here.
But one thing don't mix up
with North Korea because
their films are so different.
They got Kim Jong Un,
it doesn't make sense.
If you see them on the
silver screen there,
why do all of the actors
have the same hair?
Why? It's a dictatorial edict?
Doesn't matter though,
yeah glad we picked.
This film, first foreign language.
Let me say to the lady, make
a sandwich and she'll say no.
I rule the world because
the UK, US run by girls.
Everybody now we are in charge.
We're going to get world peace,
yeah. We're having it large.
Much better than the guys
when they start the war.
And now we're coming over
here in rows of four gonna
make sure the whole world heals, doin' it
while we're wearing nice
high heels, stilettos.
Maybe Jimmy Choos. All the
amazing peace movements you do.
You could say now we don't need you men,
gonna take my ladies to the UN.
Walk in, and there you go.
Toast high with a glass of grigio,
pinot obviously have a good time.
Every one settles down when
you share a bottle of wine.
Russia and USA, they come
together and they're like,
Oh, we should play, in a
nice way, not more cold Wars.
They get so drunk they're
rolling on the floor.
Like my mum does with
all her best friends.
February got all the best trends,
having lots of fun on every front
we go power black history month.
Gotta remember every little thing
Dr. Martin Luther King, Jr.
Malcolm X represent, and
Rosa Parks wouldn't move
when she was sent to the back of the bus.
She's like, nah, that's
not right. Gonna stand up.
Gonna have civil rights.
Gonna move on, yeah.
No apology, peace out.
Do that shit in Montgomery,
I'm going to go over here.
And I hope, I teach a
little child to pole vault.
He running up there, but I'm
not really able to teach him.
So I just get a big table.
I put it, I don't have the equipment.
He jumps up. I'm like, Oh, Whoa.
We went from the floor up there.
It would be easier if
you had a coach to take
the four meters.
Usually, that is the record.
If he had a pole, I'd be more sure.
But sadly he's over here on
my team, because I would never
give him those vaccines.
That's why kids get homeschooled.
They go, Oh no, mum it's not cool.
But don't worry, It's really on trend.
In the Olympics you'll have some friends.
All of the US team over
here one spotty little kid,
growin' no beard, sayin
I was taught by my mum.
Pole vaulting is really fun.
Have a little jump, let me get so high.
Sadly, he breaks his neck and then dies.
Ah, really sad.
He'd go get it a lot, should
have stuck to the high jump.
Maybe the Fosbury flop.
If you teach him at home
you're gettin' it wrong.
I like to teach Harry Potter
'bout the content of his wand.
What was in there you know,
they talk, it was a feather
from phoenix Fawkes shared
that stuff with Voldemort.
Professor McGonagall
should have taught him
that when the wands clash in
the fight, they would set that
whole forest up with light.
Cause they stopped him
gettin' killed in the duel.
Never thought I'd have this
much knowledge, not cool
but I read these books a whole damn lot.
All of the Harry Potter
knowledge not forgot.
I keep it in my brain and I spout it out.
My favorite teacher was Professor
Sprout, but there we go.
We're going to try and sort
it out like the sorting hat
when it's there, or about. There ya go.
(audience cheers)